pulling the camera out of the game whoa
where are we going where we going Wow
what do we just do that was amazing well
we sloppily pulled a girl from out of
the game but who cares I'm the crew the
crew we saw a we're recording yeah we
are we had a preview event where we were
playing on consoles now we've been
playing the beta for a while the bid has
been available on PC cinch i think july
so we went through a couple game modes
here obviously what they started us off
with was like some car customization
which a lot of people have probably seen
before you have your typical like you
know missions your delivery mission
without damaging a car you have your
race missions which is just pure typical
street racers you have outrun what you
have on the cops maybe protect the VIP
take down with you and I play which man
they have those in the beta but they're
freaking hard so we saw to take down
missions one of them started off on top
of the Utah Olympic Park presumably yes
120 kilometer ski jump and all the cars
jumped off so that I mean this gives you
an example of how the cruise
sensibilities are there they're very
it's out of this world it's ridiculous
in our treaty yeah it looks fun though
it looks cool it was running well on the
Xbox one yeah it's one of those that but
that takes our mission it is hard it's
very difficult it's tough it's like you
know it reminds of like you know need
for speed hot pursuit we were like you
have to damage those guys and like I
felt like in that game you could pretty
much you know you could catch up and
jump and screw them up pretty good this
one you're going through the forest on
the snow you're hitting trees your your
history like in houses my parents house
yeah I got hit anything when you got my
dog there and then we did the the I call
it The Terminator 2 level where like in
there like ditch you know like this two
nails nails of LA and you know try to
knock over a present like freeing some
prisoners or something yeah that's kind
of the story mode mission it's nuts I
mean that the course it's fun you also
have your raids and your collect
missions which we do like we're like
driving around like this Hill
countryside trying to run over drug pack
yeah you just kind of how to tap these
rubber packages they fell I have an
airplane apparently that we're smuggling
yes and they're all over to play all
over and there ever weather was
delivering that uh that that supply
really [ __ ] up yeah they dumps yeah
lots of drugs all over wine country
and then I think we went off we all we
went through the different like
performances you like your yet like your
different specs right yeah but after eat
your dirt which is like your rally car
which is kind of like what we're looking
at right now because a lot of the races
a lot of them are dirt roads yeah like
this so you had to you had to spec out
your this is this is a Nissan Z you had
to spec it out and kind of give it some
like you know offer tires and some
capabilities obviously you can see it's
insanely hard to control that was the
one thing I knew I just noticed about
this game was it was insanely difficult
to control this car because you are
going through five different
specifications and everything is so
different yeah then you go from like
circuit to raid to perform it's true
yeah whatever no yeah it just gets kind
of crazy that's gonna take some time
getting used to did you feel like the
rear wheels and I'm sure a lot of people
have this from the beta are just marbles
because the cars go like this they turn
its squirrely its squirrely and really
squirrely and that's what's so weird
about its it feels like an arcade game
an Arcadia racer like if you played test
drive unlimited like on 360 or ps4 ps2
whatever like you know like the guys
that even they made I mean and that's
who a lot of these guys are that are
from ivory tower making the crew you
know like this is kind of like the
spiritual successor of test drive
unlimited we're for so many RPG elements
in this game like they're obviously
trying to make this like a role-playing
racer which is cool and then they showed
off the 4v for PvP which is where like
you and your crew challenge and other
crew you know to various races it can be
to take down missions it can be a lot of
different things and so I like how the
four versus four in your crew faction or
whatever like I had like a you have a
weighted score right so like for example
me and Andy we had one advantage of l'a
/ on our team and finish first but me
and Andy finishing dead last but we
still tied because he carried he carried
us throughout the entire mission the
other thing they really focused almost
factions they kind of went into detail
about what factions are and its really
interesting it kind of reminds me of
like planetside 2 don't you have like
your different factions and at some
point during the story missions you'll
be able to join one of five factions in
the game it's like choosing horde and
alliance if there's like five of them
you know okay and they have control over
different parts of the country and is
that based on now to get control you if
you belong to that faction you do
missions right yes you do fashion-based
missions they can
begging me multiplayer they can be
single player but you earn reputation by
doing these missions and therefore you
make your faction stronger and you know
it's interesting they they went over
some details about how to like balance
this out and whatnot I mean obviously
the like like there were concerns about
like you know hey like what's going to
prevent people from joining the most
popular faction and just kind of taking
over the country but the thing is you're
not going to get a lot of rep points
unless you like the best in your faction
so if you're really competitive and
there's like a lot of good racers on
your particular faction it may entice
you to switch over to a different
fashion we're a lot you're much bigger
fish in a small pond essentially you
know like you're taking on more
responsibility but you're also reaping
those rewards yeah and the rewards for
having control as a fashion you get like
specialized parts you get platinum tuner
part yeah stuff like that and more money
yeah you get more money you get better
you just you get a better car
essentially yeah it was interesting you
know they talked about how they want
this game to last a long time they want
people to continue to to play the crew
for years to come and it certainly has a
huge world that I'm like that's it's a
neighbor once you get good enough at the
game I assume these these missions will
last hours or potentially could and they
even mentioned oh yeah there they want
to have a plan that you want to be
dedicated you can have a 3-hour mission
I don't know it's nuts everyone anyone
go through that and if you hit a tree
like once you're basically yeah and it's
like that's like their version of like
the raid right yeah it's like these
insanely long three-hour missions and
obviously that's to be like seeing we
have me we don't know as yet but but you
know I mean I think for those that are
their fans of test drive unlimited that
are fans of that like series and that
pedigree of Arkady type racer I think
you'll enjoy this you know you're not
tied into just one type of driving
though yeah it's like I've including the
stock model the card you purchase and so
like again I think that's the challenge
and that's also yeah the front of the
game is you're going to be able to
spec your car out you know obviously per
race and find out what exactly you need
your car to be and what it to do and you
look at these models and you can just do
some crazy stuff with your car so come
join me and Andy Bauman screw are we
gonna look at all we can be the
crocodiles we're gonna call it snow and
we're gonna have the theme song and
former okay can we actually play that by
being sued maybe the CBS on